we have to turn him back into Krupp I
know but can we just take a moment to
acknowledge what's happening here please
I mean Captain Underpants is thinking
out of that tree house well a hero's
work is never done
now it is time to fly again no no no no
wow we're by bears
oh no he's crub again ah Rolo that's it
now we know what turns them back and
forth turns who what stop why am i
soaking wet oh hey OH
thumbs up yeah we probably should this
is not doing it Frollo huh
I am captain hood where are you good
hello well hello whatever you're not ah
no I what happening I don't know let's
try and leave and see what happens
Wow what's an expensive door mm-hmm the
studio that brought you Shrek Kung Fu
Panda and Madagascar hi I'm George beard
with my best friend Harold Hutchins we
just make comics and try to make each
other laugh and this old guy is mr. crup
daughter
he's the worst principal in the world
ever since you attended its schools
you've been responsible for one in Frank
after another some of those must have
been really hard to pull off like that
tiger or that Tiger was crazy
ah I told you I could catch you one day
I'm going to have you to place exactly
good are there we're going to annihilate
the friendship don't you do something
what's the pin down mr. crup or will
hypnotize you
when I spend my fingers you will obey
our every command I'll be there go ahead
this summer comes I kick we got a stop
haha vehicle person oh yeah which Robin
you'll get them their greatest creation
Captain Underpants you can't actually
fly I take to the sky like an awesome
wow he is super dumb it is now biggest
problem dad's out you [ __ ] up
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon hi
Eclair I'm a cool teacher not some scary
guy with a secret evil agenda guys I
don't we got ya ugly he's got it
Kevin Hart and helm Thomas Middleditch
it crawl
when it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants more so
you're trapped in some sort of invisible
box like prison is it okay that I'm kind
of loving this yes enough I will set you
free
Oh mostly yes
you